from oracle park in san francisco
opening day
2022 on mlb the show it's the oakland
athletics taking on the san francisco
giants
[Applause]
and we'll be back with the first pitch
right after this
shortstop
elvis
the pitch
and the lefty with the 0-1
line to left
ruff makes the play and there's one down
[Applause]
chad pinder digs in down
[Applause]
started after it tried to hold up now a
look to first nope he held back
and the pitch
check swing but he went too far and the
count wanted one
lefty ready and a 1-1
that misses the zone two-and-one
[Applause]
[Music]
next offering upstairs
two out spaces empty and stepping in is
the speedy christian pacquiao
that one drilled left field that's back
that's back some more turning looking
and that one is gone
two outs nobody on austin allen up next
for the a's
they say you win well off to a great
start he's really cruising out there on
the mound he's got a chance to get
through these first two innings with
under 20 pitches that could set him up
to go deep into this game
two outs
popped up
no trouble here puts it away for the owl
and that'll do
it bottom of the second now it's the
giants catcher kurt cosali
right-hander back to work
pitches in for a strike strike one
check swing went around and that is
strike two
[Applause]
[Applause]
and the o2
starting to go after it now we'll look
down to first and that's rule to swing
it's a strikeout
and up next for san francisco wilmer
flores
and first off ring is fouled off
one down base is empty
inside just missed
[Applause]
so a foul ball makes it one and two
[Music]
kicks and deals
and the one two misses to even the count
and it's fouled away some real good life
going through the zone on that one
hawaii to kick the pitch
cracks his bat and pops him up and
that's a foul ball
2-2
and a foul bald he stays alive
two-two now
in the air left field
tender under it
he makes the grab two away
mike yaski up here
the wine to the pitch
that one's in there and that is strike
one
next offering misses and it's two and
one
swaying and a miss two and two
[Applause]
here's the 2-2
stays alive
and that one fouled off
eighth pitch of the at back coming up
[Applause]
and a swing and a miss and that's that
back here in san francisco all set for
the start of the unit digging in for
oakland steven vogt kind of a throwback
no batting gloves
and the first pitch misses for ball one
they say who went
[Applause]
next offering is in for a strike
one and two here
that misses now two and two
[Applause]
there's a swing and a drive
that's back
that one is gone
[Applause]
here's jed lowry the switch hitter
batting right got it none
the first baseman number eight
yeah daddy dies
one ripped left field that's bad
pulls it in on the warning track
here's sean murphy now
catcher
sean
murphy
the pitch
he was late there strike one well he
looks fresh out there just
needs to get a little more confidence
and remember how good he's been in the
past
[Applause]
and now the lefty
up the middle
and there's the hit
next up for the a's tony kemp
[Music]
the pitch
[Applause]
on the ground right side four
six drops it but they're saying it was
on the transfer
[Music]
rojo back to work
gets under and pops it up
flores makes the catch and that'll do it
the ball game we're talking about middle
innings and can get a little length out
of this arm
coming out of the bullpen we'll see just
how many outs he's able to give his
skipper bart at the plate and takes high
there
swinging a miss as he was late now these
guys definitely looking for a big swing
of the bat right here try to close that
gap but you know at the very least if
you could find a way to manufacture that
run from first it feels like it's really
important that getting back into this
ball game starting to go up to 2-1
appeal down to first and he went says
dave lawrence
next offering upstairs
[Applause]
stays alive
the giants yet to pick up a hit here
on the ground left side six
gets it to first one away bottom of the
six
up to the plate is brandon bellis
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
not even close
[Applause]
the pitch
and now two balls in a strike well
notice they've been pitching him hard
inside and the key is if you're going to
make a mistake you've got to make it off
the ditch if it leaks out over the plate
with this kind of power we'd be asking
for a new baseball
the giants
still looking for their first hit in
this one
got him huge strikeout there
[Applause]
here's brandon crawford and this is a
big opportunity for him to pick up his
teammate right there
yeah he swings and misses and it's
nothing in one
next offering is in for a strike
strike three got him swinging
out number three
johnny
taking over on the mound it's his job to
keep his team in the game
we go to the top of the seventh chad
pinder now
the right-hander back to work
that first offering is fouled off
kick sandhills
check swing but he went too far and
account is owen two
out towards center slater has a bead on
it and there's one away
here's christian poche he's already
homered in this game
in the pitch
that one is absolutely belted way
back and that one's gone into the
bleachers
giants in striking distance but have
some work to do it starts with the laid
off man i need a good bat out of him
right here
and the pitch
that one hammered center field way back
there
[Music]
and next will be the cleanup hitter
darren ruff
and the pitch
out to short
into the outfield base hit
[Applause]
how much of a distraction those fans
behind home plate are to the opposing
pitcher i mean they are into it they're
trying to will this claw back into this
ball game
ruff gets his lead at first nobody out
next offering is foul back
and that one fouled off while he's
having a tough time getting a pitch by
him as a hitter you feel pretty
confident that you're seeing different
pitches still able to make some type of
contact
the tying run at the plate
in the air to left center pace he ranges
to his right makes the catch
one down
and now it's wilmer flores he's kind of
an outlier especially when guys are
consciously sacrificing contact to
deliver power
comes up empty on the swing only two now
yeah his swing is so good it's in the
zone a long time he gets the barrel to
it a lot and that produces more base
hits
[Applause]
it fouled off
[Applause]
owen chew now
and a foul ball he stays alive
at the belton
fires that one is lifted in the air
brown settles under it and makes the
catch then there's two down
mike ustremski up here
the pit the right vehicle
next offering is in for a strike
[Applause]
fly ball down the line
kinder makes the catch
so the giants with a new pitcher on the
hill jose alvarez
and he'll do his best to keep this close
well i think that what makes him so
tough against left-handers as he hides
the ball for a long time and from that
same side
harder for you to determine which part
of the plate it's going to end up on
your strengths on the move to his right
base hit
into second easily with a lead off
double
here's sean murphy
now
[Applause]
pitch
check swing but he went too far and
that's strike one
[Applause]
jack swing went around no balls two
strikes
[Applause]
pitches downstairs recognize that change
up right out of the hand just spit on it
the one two
the punch out there
not what you're looking for after the
lead off double a strikeout and there's
one away
digging in for oakland tony kenneth
here comes the pitch
puts it in the air out towards left
center
rough makes the play and there's two
down
safe at second not tagging at second and
there's two gone
now
and here comes up the middle
flores over to pick it up tosses the
first and that is the third out of the
inning
ready for the bottom of the eighth
the
it's pitch tough for the offense so far
but you can't get frustrated you got to
find a way to shake it off go up there
and relax that's the only way you're
going to be able to put runs up on the
board that's a hit
off to a good start for the lead off now
round second digging for third
and he's got a lead off triple
this is joey barton
and the pitch
[Music]
[Applause]
lifted in the air right center field
a big run scores on the sac fly they
trail by one it's 3-2
ramsey the pitch
yeah in the box now takes a cold strike
he didn't want to give up that run but
he did got the fly ball sac fly out now
it's time to attack these other guys get
your team back in the dugout
center field pache under it
squeezes it and there's two away
brandon crawford
and the pit stop
ball one no strap
[Applause]
and a foul ball
no signs of wavering on the mound here
in the eighth he's looking rock solid so
far
[Applause]
and there's it here
two out base hit keeps the inning alive
now it's evan longoria's turn one for
three to the gun
the third baseman
the pitch
typically the outfield defense will play
a little bit deeper just to keep the
ball in front make sure that runner on
first doesn't come all the way around
the score and tie this ball game up
and that's ripped into left base hit and
it's off the wall
and into second easily with a two out
double
with the right-hander back to work
big spot
two out both the tying and go ahead runs
are aboard
owen two as he waves at that one very
solid inning on the mound so far here in
the eighth holding on to this narrow
lead this is exactly what they were
looking for
[Applause]
next offering is foul back
[Applause]
swing and a miss and he got him good job
of damage control right there
a new arm into the game the righty tyler
beatty and his job is to collect quick
outs and keep his team within striking
distance
the wind of the pitch
bounced up the middle
crawford throws the first in time going
up on down
one run game here in the top of the
ninth
[Applause]
they say
up next for the a's
the wine of the
[Applause]
and that is ball wall not looking like
they'll be adding any insurance runs
hitting the bottom of the ninth so it's
going to be on the ball pin to hold this
lead
and that one in the air center field
slater makes the catch and that'll do it
back here at the ballpark and here's the
catcher kurt casalli and there's no
doubt that they'll feed off the energy
from this crowd right i mean yeah i'd
say the intensity level has gone up a
few notches for sure
next pitch is inside and the count is
2-0 well an interesting situation one
swing you can tie up the ball game but
if you're patient and work a walk when
you bring the game-winning run to the
plate
there's the strike three and one
and he walked him
wilmer flores the next giant to hit
chris baseball today so many strikeouts
and they are available to pitchers but
this is a guy that puts the bat on the
ball and is kind of different from the
players that we see day in day out and
that gets down for a base hit
lead runner to seconds a two on and
nobody out
mike yastremski the next giant to hit
all right
that's outside and that's ball
next offering is in for a strike
[Applause]
in the air right field round drifts
towards it and there's one down
safe at second and he gets back in maybe
caught that one off the end just a
little bit couldn't quite barrel it up
enough to really drive the team trevino
back to work
and that's ball one he's looking for a
ground ball to get a double play and out
of this jam
the 1-1 is cut on and missed the pitch
upstairs
and that one
wrapped foul
the one two
and a swing and a miss
and there's two away
a big spot here bottom of the night
down to their final out and now it's the
giants dh joey bart you got the number
nine hole hitter right here looking to
do whatever he can to get on base turn
this line up over so the best hitters in
this lineup have a chance to tie up the
ball game or maybe even walk it off
these home fans they are making a lot of
noise putting pressure
on that pitcher out there
[Applause]
as this one is over well all you want is
a chance going to that final frame they
got some base runners had the tying run
at second the winning run at first just
couldn't come through with the big hit
on the other side
nice job to battle through it blows out
the win 3-2 the finals score oakland
victorious for chris singleton and our
entire crew i'm john shaw saying so long
you